تمكنت حمله التبرعات اطلقتها 213 محطه
تلفزيونيه و562 اذاعه داخل تركيا بالاضافه
الى قنوات واذاعات في اذربيجان وقبرص
التركيه تحت عنوان تركيا قلب واحد من انه
تجمع سته مليارات دولار خلال 7 ساعات من
البث المباشر لاغاثه متضرري الزلزال في
تركيا الحمله شارك فيها اهم واكبر النجوم
الاتراك ولاقت دعم شعبي كبير واهتمام
سياسيين رياضيين ويعني الاهتمام حقيقه
تمثل بحجم المبلغ كمان اللي تم جمعهم وعلى
فكره الحمله ببساطه هي بث مباشر على كل
المنصات مثل ما قلنا وفيها النجوم على
مراحل شاركوا عبر تقديم البث وتلقي
اتصالات المتبرعين بانفسهم
[موسيقى]
ومن ايام كمان انطلقت حمله التبرعات شبيهه
في سوريا حملت اسم لاهلي والبث المباشر
فيها استمرت 72 ساعه عبر اثير اذاعه شام
اف ام من دمشق وكمان شارك فيها عدد من
الفنانين السوريين والاعلاميين لكن لافت
في هذه الحمله انه ما في اي اخبار عن كم
جمعت للان والحمله لسه شغاله وتمت تمديدها
12 ساعه اضافيه وحنشوف عاد بعدها يعني
حيعلنوا المبلغ او لا وعلى فكره في سوريا
للان ما في اي احصائيه للخسائر ولا اي
معلومات عن حجم الدمار في المناطق
المتضرره
[موسيقى]